the opposition is on high alert I'm
talking threat level red DEFCON 1 diaper
fall now obviously we all know why this
week one of the most influential
organizations in the world launched an
attack against everything we thought we
knew the International House of Pancakes
is flipping its p4 Abbi I hop announcing
on Twitter that it will now be called AI
hub and we'll explain why on Monday some
people are downright outraged grace
tweeting quote someone sue I hop for
changing their name what kind of Anarchy
is this yeah this is anarchy I haven't
been this rattled by a threat since
Gloria Stefan said the rhythm is gonna
get you got a minute I'm still a little
skittish around Congress I hop the
letter that was broken in your name
wasn't the P it was the i-4
International I hate the fact that my
creative face pancake is made in a
globalist Enclave full of espionage and
french-toast opposers we can't wait till
Monday we need to know what in God's
name I hub is planning because the
mainstream media isn't going to help us
through this crisis all their ideas are
terrible the best guess is that it will
become an International House of
breakfast no official word yet on what
that B will stand for although it's
thought to be breakfast the most common
and our producers think most likely is
of course breakfast it's gonna be
breakfast I by hob first off thanks MSM
for covering this hard news
but you're absolutely wrong it can't be
breakfast that's what the B and cardi B
stands for carne breakfast
if Wikipedia disagrees change it I dare
you besides breakfast would be too
simple too obvious too undeserving of an
entire ad campaign with a fall week's
lead into the rollout it has to be
something else all hands on deck citizen
journalist Laura gray eye hub what is
the B easy Jordan say hello to the
International House of Benghazi with
today's special dish the rooty tooty
fresh and Hillary did it right so you're
all in on Benghazi aren't you Jordan are
we yes of course
Laura Tim bolts what is the B Jordan
it's clear the feminists are behind this
why else would they remove the p4 penis
and replace it with a B for vagina
you realize vagina starts with a V right
impossible if it's not the feminists
then why does the OB in the new IHOP
logo look exactly like the secret logo
on the secret box that only my mother
and sister were ever allowed to touch
little did they know I used to steal him
and turn him into very soft nunchucks
for my GI Joes no bad ideas Tim Josh
Erin what is the B Jordan the B is just
phase one next they're gonna take the H
and twist it around turn the oside way
so it becomes an O and change the B into
an S just because and suddenly I hop is
Isis
Isis the terrorists are playing a long
game they're going to slowly kill us
over the next 40 years with high carb
high sugar breakfast the terrorists are
gonna win through diabetes this is worse
than I thought it's a full-on I hop
ellipse we will be on this story all
week because we only have five days left
to crack this code and I swear to god it
better not be breakfast I'm serious I
have set your syrupy ass down and hear
me when I say if that B just stands for
breakfast I'm going to come down there
to the blue roof right off your
globalist pancake hurry put your short
stacks at the waffle maker and send you
back to whatever hashbrown hell you came
from the fight continues good you hid
down here with the real truth lies you
want to help me defeat the globalists
and stay on the inside click and
subscribe and help me defeat them
because following me on my youtube
channel
makes you a leader it tracks trust me